okay it's your boy psychobabble doing
butcher's bill okay and it's your boy um
you know oh [ __ ] it's your boy uh you
know uh Donald Trump here ok sorry I was
like go nuts ok this one where do we
gotta [ __ ] go [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok yeah put my foot up the chair it's
gonna fall asleep but you know [ __ ] it I
asked how lonely blades once you know
and only live once with an [ __ ] you
know like only have one life with an
[ __ ] you know like this [ __ ] is
just alright Jay okay I love with 25
batches 25 where the [ __ ] my god over
here
[ __ ] I got here ago
runnin I'm runnin I'm so much faster
than running favorite bang yeah yeah
yeah okay where do I go now okay I got a
fast travel let's do this okay okay
let's do this baby yeah let's do this
baby baby baby let's do this baby for
you go to let's do this baby so I can't
touch a better yeah all right what is
what is long okay I gotta go east gotta
gotta go fat uh hello haha ok it's weird
just [ __ ] dog just shown here
you
let that [ __ ] were my god so this is
[ __ ] disgusting this is gonna suck
major dick push strong well he can
actually shred through [ __ ] like crazy
okay let's see how I let's see ya yes
yes quick save quick site Kendall
Kendall okay okay candle hi oh Jesus ok
I guess to do this
attack that's a douche bags no it's this
loans just getting its and oh shut and
exit okay what is it it's deep no it's
free oh it's a fine just kidding okay
let's say it's struck and now it's thug
if that's 10 that's got ya I can show up
okay good good okay get in there oh
hello sir okay okay well a lot of [ __ ]
here right no no just kidding ain't [ __ ]
here nice little nice little pile here
solo orgy huh look this large a very
cute very cute
ok I see the Raiders just literally
having orgies here said absolutely
execution thought they liked about
strong as he loves violence you know and
I admire that ok shut God yeah
here stairs here stairs am I gonna [ __ ]
up up here uh anyone anyone what is that
anyone anyone here hello hello show your
face oh ok can I do a far shot no there
we go let's see if we can get on now God
God good kid Oh more or Jays wow wow
that is just bizarre yeah baby oh baby
oh baby really [ __ ] snap it going turn
other doors like feel like I'm missing
something is that I throat no [ __ ] or
I'm on the right level at least
okay okay tell me to go up yeah I miss
something what is this okay okay so
where the [ __ ] out what's the store no
not a door not a door oh here we go
let's do this let's do this I'm just I'm
just a look quick saver all right strong
summit ice on you that's what happens
you leave your beers here I clean up
after you I love cleaning its Gregor
just the [ __ ] [ __ ]
somebody not spin the bottle
the [ __ ] going on here oh
who's there yeah worst nightmare bitcha
man sai khao yai thought [ __ ] up I'm
here Brett says he is really scum okay
Milo's people try not to kill me i don't
know if i can get this guy but I'm gonna
try [ __ ] see firstly I'll emanate this
and then i elevate this guy no no no no
yes sir okay you just don't know what
fair means in our language ok you shut
that guy yes yeah fast side is that the
[ __ ] is in here ok think it could be a
bobblehead
like me strong good i'm just going
straight there don't [ __ ] in the left
why'd it change half my laser mouse yet
ok I don't know the quickest way out of
this place yeah yeah get-get gut Oh sexy
beautiful huh what is your name I simply
must now ok ok ok yes yes sorry gotta go
down again
I was that noise okay I get it now
[ __ ] mist on my critical that's okay
that's okay you know I'm just looking I
get home chef
okay I'm looking just to get the [ __ ]
out of here luck in to get the [ __ ] out
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this [ __ ]
don't work like it used to be yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah my lies less working does
anyone know why that is not working all
right scared what okay good no no no Stu
she says
that was eyelet how silent [ __ ] ok good
ok dad kept up
[ __ ] [ __ ] a which way to go will
trace down left or right okay run it run
it run it run it run ok gud gud gud he
can't go in this room he's to peg Anna
oh [ __ ] I didn't know it's [ __ ]
radiation answering why is there so much
radiation in here I can't get out of
here oh it is cool those are car it's a
memory bank [ __ ] release the latch ok
I did not sign up for this Michael don't
you get it I don't like this type of
behavior
where is it going click running away I
gotta put in that insane like shotgun
thing where is it oh I have a sniper
rifle holy [ __ ] here um don't I have
yeah cute this is right here that is
badass ok let's [ __ ] faster a lot of
here do some right away some park
advance and then let's map travel out of
this [ __ ] cat cat gut gut gut the
fastest way to a man's heart is through
his penis you know hey Rocky goodnight
Augusta Street house was destroyed
thanks